buona sera io mi chiamo lucia giuliano
nella vita precedente fino a cinque anni
fa era un architetto
adesso mi occupo di scuole di formazione
del futuro non so ancora cosa farò
questo è il luogo da cui vengo dalle
pendici del vulcano etna 1 nel vulcano
attivo più alto d europa un sistema
dinamico in continua evoluzione una
grande montagna di 3.500 metri che ad
ogni eruzione si trasforma modifica la
sua altezza la sua con cui la sua
configurazione alla sua forma appunto un
sistema dinamico che cambia
continuamente proprio come il mondo
contemporaneo
più precisamente è questo il luogo da
cui sono partita ieri mattina per venire
qui fino a caserta un antica villa di
fine settecento appunto alle pendici
dell'etna costruita da una nobile
famiglia catanese capi trascorreva le
vacanze estive era situata al centro di
una grande distesa di vigneti e di
agrumeti che oggi hanno lasciato il
posto una grande distesa di villette e
condomini che abbiamo accuratamente
cercato di non far vedere dalla foto in
questo luogo nel 1992 quindi più di
venti anni fa un gruppo di persone tra
cui alcuni componenti della mia famiglia
decidono di fondare una accademia di
belle arti che firmasse degli operatori
nel campo del restauro
questo è il vecchio proprietario di casa
e questo è uno dei quadri su cui
lavoravano gli studenti in vent'anni di
storia della scuola il mondo è cambiato
tantissimo
si è trasformato è cambiata la geografia
è cambiata la politica è cambiata
l'economia è cambiato il mondo in cui
noi ci relazioniamo è cambiato dal modo
in cui comunichiamo è cambiato tutto e
la scuola aveva anche bisogno di
trasformarsi di dotarsi di nuovo
progetto
e così che nel 2010 io insieme un gruppo
di persone
decidiamo di trasformare la scuola e di
trasformarla in una scuola di design
perché il design è perché è una scuola
cos'è il design se chiedessimo a 10
persone diverse una definizione di
design avremmo 10 definizioni diverse
perché è difficile da descrivere in modo
univoco
se dovessi dirlo io il design è la
disciplina che ci aiuta a trasformarci
ci aiuta a modificarsi continuamente ad
adattarci a un contesto luogo a un
sistema di condizione di parametri in
questo senso mi sembra una disciplina
chiave per il mondo contemporaneo
una giornalista che scrive per il new
york times che parla di design nel suo
libro è la world lei si chiama el'ice
rolston dice il cui il design come
progettare un grattacielo un gene un
software un menù una strategia
corporativa
un designer può essere uno stilista che
si occupa di abiti o un progettista di
interni essere un creazionista
esagerando ovviamente può essere
addirittura dio
crediamo che il design per il luogo in
cui questa scuola si trovava però essere
una disciplina molto importante in
questo senso abbiamo iniziato
completamente a rivoluzionare la scuola
proprio perché pensando anche che il
design tanto trasformato la nostra vita
la trasforma continuamente ha generato
cose molto importanti nella storia per
la società per esempio 4 velocissimi
esempi per farci capire quanto il design
che in inglese significa to design
significa essenzialmente progettare
quanto il progetto ha modificato la vita
di tutti noi
sono esempi dell'inizio del secolo
questa è una delle prime lavatrici che
modificato moltissimo la vita delle
donne che grazie a questo strumento si
sono liberate di una schiavitù
importante era quella di lavare giorno
dopo giorno metri cubi direi
di roba questo è un altro oggetto molto
importante credo per tutto il novecento
la penna bic anche questa inventata
dagli inizi del novecento che ha già
nella prima trasformazione veramente
radicale del modo in cui grazie a questo
oggetto possiamo scrivere portare dietro
lo strumento per per prendere appunti e
per scrivere siamo passati dall
inchiostro il pennino a un oggetto
portatile che tutt'oggi non è mai
cambiato è sempre lo stesso è tutto
usiamo questo un altro prodotto di
design interessante il ghiacciolo che è
stato inventato da un bambino di 11 anni
negli stati uniti che dimentica una
notte il suo bicchiere pieno di soda con
un bastoncino per i mescolarlo al di
fuori dalla sua finestra in una fredda
gelida notte d'inverno e lo trova
l'indomani ghiacciato
e scopre si rende conto che poteva
mangiarlo e così disegna il ghiacciolo
brevetta il ghiacciolo arriva fino ai
nostri giorni sappiamo tutti cos'è
questo è un altro oggetto che ognuno di
noi in questo momento nella sua borsa o
dentro la tasca uno smartphone uno degli
oggetti che oggi più rivoluziona la vita
di tutti i giorni
anche questo è un oggetto di design in
cui c'è tecnologia grafica c'è prodotto
informatica c'è software di tutto perché
nasce dal lavoro di squadra riflettessi
progettisti e che l'oggetto che modifica
il modo in cui noi comunichiamo e
facciamo tantissime cose oggi perché poi
la scuola perché in questo mondo che è
così velocemente è radicalmente cambiato
in questi ultimi anni la scuola è una
delle cose che più lentamente cambia che
tende a rimanere fatic che faticosamente
cerca di fare il salto di adattamento
acquistano la società questa è una foto
dell'inizio del secolo di una classe di
una scuola
se entriamo in una classe oggi
probabilmente troveremo il proiettore
che una volta non c'era ma quanto è
diversa questa classe dalla classe di un
secolo fa
purtroppo non tanto purtroppo poco
in una società liquida che dicevamo
appunto in continua trasformazione il
design secondo noi deve anche cambiare
la scuola e deve aiutarci a progettare a
dominare a controllare questo
cambiamento da cui siamo continuamente
circondati come lo facciamo noi ci
troviamo noi come avete visto in un
luogo periferico anche remoto
dell'europa in sicilia e lavoriamo a tre
scale
lavoriamo alla scala locale con quella
che noi chiamiamo una scuola che la
intendiamo come una palestra un
allenamento continuo
quando parlo con i miei studenti io dico
sempre non esiste un manuale di mille
pagine che voi leggete fino alla fine e
alla fine del quale siete un progettista
l'unico modo per imparare ad essere
progettisti e allenarsi tutti i giorni
come se ci sta come se fossimo degli
sportivi che ci stiamo allenando per le
olimpiadi 3 anni 4 anni 5 anni con un
continuo allenamento
grazie alle guide giuste questo è
l'unico modo per diventare dei
progettisti alla scala locale lo
facciamo
quindi lavorando lavorando tutti i
giorni lavorando duro giorno dopo giorno
invitando persone avvenire in sicilia da
ogni parte del mondo e creando questo
allenamento continuo lo facciamo anche
però ad un'altra scala alla scala
nazionale del paese alla scala
dell'italia ci siamo infatti in 20 menta
ti un nuovo formato che abbiamo chiamato
design dedicato a un modo di intendere
il design nel senso di costruire le
relazioni abbiamo chiamato design delle
relazioni del design relazionale e serve
proprio a trasmettere agli studenti
attraverso un allenamento molto
intensivo che essere un progettista
significa anche e soprattutto saper
costruire relazioni tra le cose i luoghi
le persone le aziende le istituzioni le
città eccetera
gli studenti lavorano e su una classe
virtuale su google plus dove
interagiscono tra di loro è
interagiscono con i docenti e viaggiano
per tutto l'anno
ogni mese si spostano in un luogo e si
incontrano in una città diversa dove
fanno un'esperienza diversa di progetto
grazie a questo formato inedito il
nostro master mette insieme studenti che
vengono da tutta italia non più soltanto
studenti siciliani o studenti che da
tutta l'italia viaggia lo si incontrano
e interagiscono e si allenano al
progetto
questa è un'immagine della piattaforma
di google plus è aperta a tutti e dove
avviene grandi una prima parte molto
importante dell'interazione e dello
scambio e quindi emerge qui un tema
abbastanza importante la relazione che
esiste tra i media e la scuola credo che
questo sia sarà un tema fondante di
molti degli speech delle di questa
serata perché effettivamente i media
hanno oggi cambiato molto il modo in cui
comunichiamo è sicuramente devono
cambiare anche la scuola mi piaceva a
ricordare questo questo programma
televisivo del 1952 che ho scoperto
perché io allora ancora non c'ero del
famoso maestro manzi
che appunto grazie a questo programma
televisivo riesce a portare l'educazione
attraverso la televisione in giro per
l'italia è che grazie a questo programma
parac più di un milione e mezzo di
persone in un periodo in cui
l'analfabetizzazione era molto diffusa
riescono a prendere la licenza
elementare la televisione diventa lo
strumento fondamentale per questa opera
importante realta alfabetizzazione
oggi si parla invece di
analfabetizzazione digitale pare che
l'italia sia uno dei paesi in cui questo
fenomeno sia abbastanza diffuso e più di
un terzo della popolazione è ancora
digitalmente analfabeta
e questo mi porta a parlare di quello
che di quella che posso chiamare la
scala globale con cui noi facciamo
scuola è un esperimento che abbiamo
iniziato a fare l'anno scorso
un corso online destinato a studenti di
tutto il mondo è totalmente gratuito
siamo stati infatti selezionati da una
startup tedesca che ha sede a berlino
che ha inaugurato lo scorso anno questa
piattaforma per il mood europeo
non so se conoscete questo fenomeno dei
mood è una parola inglese e americana
che viene dagli stati di un fenomeno
molto presente negli stati uniti book
significa massive online open corses
sono corsi online totalmente gratuiti
operati da università anche molto famose
e che consentono di raggiungere
l'educazione anche persone che vivono in
paesi remoti che non riescono a
frequentare le università c'è un
tentativo riportare questo questi nuclei
in europa ai versi ti lancia l'anno
scorso vinse lo scorso anno un concorso
al quale partecipiamo e credo che il
fatto che noi una scuola molto remota
molto piccola e molto periferica riesce
ad essere selezionata per il bouquet
dovuto anche al fatto che la selezione
veniva essenzialmente online grazie
proprio alla forza dei nuovi media che
ci portano ad essere tra i primi
selezionati
questo è il nostro professore il nostro
maestro manzi e stefano mirti ed è
insieme infatti a un gruppo di milano
che si chiama id lab che portiamo avanti
questo progetto
questa è la pagina web che adesso
raccoglie l'archivio di tutte le
elezioni il corso si chiamava design 101
design basics era essenzialmente tutto
in inglese ogni lezione era costituita
da un video di presentazione del tema e
da un pdf in cui veniva lanciato
l'argomento del giorno gli esercizi del
giorno e gli studenti interagivano tra
di loro su la piattaforma della
diversity ma anche su tutti i social
media facebook twitter e instagram e
google plus che diventano lo strumento
attraverso il quale la comunicazione
continua a girare a diffondersi a
crescere questo è uno dei primi video
che abbiamo fatto di introduzione al
corso
eye want to the wall ref found the only
thing che misura changing
waiting son berlin levin picnic de noia
national gallery chirurgo del brief dei
complete qui in get ready this week
cargo work hard
questo ci ha consentito di creare la
classe quella che ho chiamato della
classe più grande del mondo
alcuni numeri per darvi un'idea di che
significa avere un corso online 42 1895
studenti si sono iscritti al corso
10.025 hanno iniziato il corso 629 sono
arrivati fino alla fine
350 che sono un certificato 300 hanno
consegnato il progetto per l'esposizione
finale e cento di loro da tutto il mondo
hanno viaggiato fino a berlino dove
abbiamo appunto esposto tutti i progetti
questo è un breve grafico che
spiega un po da dove arriva la
popolazione studentesca che abbiamo
siamo riusciti a mettere insieme una
parte una percentuale importante dal
brasile dall'india abbastanza grande e
anche dall'italia degli stati uniti
eccetera eccetera
e questo ci dà la dimensione della
potenza della forza dei new media che ci
consentono di fare scuola anche in un
altro modo
lui negli ultimi video che chiudeva il
corso
ciao cani se dei no quella ex designer
esiste
grinza ammazzare il suo ex
se poi si chiude o immagini the strange
per i vari con statement del fiume il
fuoriclasse dei quando banale g n roses
the world the wendy talent trigger
street making poi dei final chief
division
l'esposizione che abbiamo fatto a
berlino a chiusura del corso è stato un
modo per noi perché questa esperienza
non fosse soltanto relegata al mondo
virtuale alla dimensione digitale quindi
abbiamo chiesto a quei 100 studenti che
poi hanno deciso di partecipare di
spedire il blu flowers il progetto di un
fiore blu per l'esposizione di berlino e
questi sono tutti i pacchi arrivati da
tutto il mondo per per l'esposizione e
questa è un'immagine appunto di tutti
questi fiori messi insieme
mettere insieme digitale fisico credo
che sia una delle cose più importanti
che dobbiamo cercare e che noi cerchiamo
di fare con le nostre attività
perché anche se siamo molto anche se la
dimensione virtuale una nuova dimensione
della nostra esistenza
siamo sempre persone fatte di carne e
ossa che ci muoviamo in un mondo fisico
e quindi far intrecciare così due lei è
continuamente credo che sia la cosa più
importante
questo è il nostro simbolo la nostra
bandiera che segna che marca il nostro
luogo il nostro territorio abbiamo
iniziato quasi cinque anni fa con dieci
studenti
adesso siamo arrivati a 70 senza contare
quelli sparsi in tutto il mondo e credo
che il progetto è il design progetto di
una scuola sia una delle cose più
importanti a cui tutti dovremo prestare
attenzione
grazie